uh you got the Mac Dre tattoo uh I feel
like not a lot of people understand like
kind of the dynamic of Mac Dre's career
would you say that he wasn't fully
appreciated
until he passed away
kinda
but I feel like I feel like he was
appreciated but
a lot it was a lot of people that didn't
know who Dre was Tilly died so the
[ __ ] that did know Dre he had a
crazy fan base that's what I'd always
heard like that it was more like the
white boys the Berkeley guys like kind
of the nerdy like rap dudes who were
like super tapped in with Mac Dre yeah
they were super tough then it was like
when you say that it was like his fans
like those were like his core of real
films you got blacks and every you feel
me right of course of course of course
right probably not as much but when he
passed away I feel like his influence
was really felt yeah man he had so much
music bro he was he has so much [ __ ]
that's my favorite rapper so I I know
everything from the start to the end
like that's your goat that's that's my
goat right there oh God [ __ ] asked me
who my favorite rappers Trey is number
one who's number two
give me the top five
my this my me your personal favorite my
personal favorite of course uh Dre
the old Little Boosie okay
um
Messy Marv
I don't even think I got a top five
that's three it's a good three the old
Lil Boosie not a fan of the new Lil
Boosie I mean out here
I'll get it wrong new Lil Boosie cool
but I I when I if I'm gonna play some
Lil Boosie you can play old [ __ ] I'm
playing all all little boost in my mind
playing though him and Webby all that I
just pulled up here slapping Webby just
now shout out to Webbie man I wish Webby
would do more [ __ ] I feel like he should
do a podcast or something because he's
hilarious whatever he was hard yeah it
was crazy
if I had to go to my homicide pot and
and 40. that's fair Tupac and 40. yeah
yeah